[Music]
chuck
what's up neil we're back at it ah must
be time to explain
you you're my
you you're my explainer guinea pig
that's it
i get to i get to i get to get the test
case for all
nations for all millions who will see
this on youtube that's right
okay so a couple of things uh
i want to talk about the sun all right
okay son
[Laughter]
s-u-n the day after which
sunday is named okay
did you know that yeah yeah sun sunday i
don't know
i mean it only has the word in it
sunday's named after the sun the seven
days of the week are named after the
seven
classical planets just so you know and
god's related to those planets
so saturday guess is named after whom uh
saturn
saturn and moon day uh the moon i gave
you a hint there
because you called it moon day so here
we go
and the other is you have to go to the
god equivalent that
ruled the planet and then you get the
you can flush out
the seven classical planets which were
mercury venus mars
jupiter saturn the sun and the moon
there you go the seven objects that
would wander against the background
stars
and the greek word for wanderer is
planitus
that's very cool yeah yeah yeah okay so
the sun
what's interesting to me is
our vocabulary to describe what's going
on in the sky
is pre-copernican so copernicus
around 500 years ago uh wrote a book
called the revolutionibus which was on
the revolutions of the heavenly bodies
and he realized that
maybe earth is not in the center of all
motion he should have named that book
it's not all about you
that's good it probably would have sold
better you know
the world's first psychiatrist it's not
about you it's not about you and
it's not your fault right it's not your
fault it's not your fault
okay so our vocabulary reflects
earth being in the center of the known
universe
we don't say what time does the
sun come into position
such that its upper limb becomes visible
over the rotating horizon of earth
no we just ask when sunrise when is
sunrise
exactly so there's a certain simplicity
to thinking that we are in the center of
all things
but don't forget that that entire
vocabulary predates the discovery
and affirmation that the sun is in the
center of that motion and not earth
so i just want to say that so now
so we have the sun moving across the sky
so sunlight was generated in the center
of the sun we did a whole explainer
video
on how the sunlight gets out of the sun
and then it comes through the empty
space
all right gaps that distance in eight
minutes and 20 seconds then it moves
through our atmosphere
and then it reaches your eyeballs okay
thus light through the vacuum of space
moves at the speed of light
when it goes through earth's atmosphere
it is no longer moving at the speed of
light
it slows down it slows down okay okay
anytime light slows down coming at an
angle
into a medium the path of light
bends the physics term for that is
refreshed
it reflects much like a straw do people
still use straws
no no yeah they're paper straws now yeah
now you have a spiral
i remember those okay i'm old enough to
remember when all straws were paper
and you couldn't drink milkshakes out of
it because the straw would collapse
right and then if you use the straw too
long the straw would get water logged
and it would just be completely useless
okay so i have straw issues at the
moment but i'll get over them
all right so if you put a straw in a
half filled cup of water
tilted you'll see that the straw bends
the light
bent on its way out of the liquid into
the air
of the straw so that bending is no
different
physically from going from vacuum to air
to different medium
of different densities okay i say all
this because
as the sun approaches the horizon
to set it's actually
moving faster than you see it to be
so refraction is taking the sun
lower than the actual position on the
sky you think the sun
is oh that's oh man it's crazy
to watch so watch so what's up great so
watch
yeah so when the glowing sun
is on the horizon right the sun has
already set
yes that's amazing i love it
i love it so the atmosphere is actually
taking the
light and bending it in such a way
that you are seeing a sunset that has
really already happened or it happened
five minutes ago yeah
you missed it
okay oh that's that's really cool
so what it means is if you had some
super missile
okay and you aimed it at the setting sun
and it could get there instantly they
would just miss it it would just fly off
into space
because that's not where the sun is
that's the image of the sun
bent into a direct line of for your line
of sight
oh that's okay so all right so now watch
that's great
that's really great but wait there's
more
and if i act now
you want two for one i connect right
can i just pay shipping and handling
here's two for one
so now that's sunset okay how about
sunrise
well the same thing is happening is
playing out on the other side of the sky
when you okay when you see the sun rise
the sun is still below the horizon and
has not yet risen
wow okay that it's doing the same thing
in reverse so it's
referring to the light it's bending it
and you're seeing light
back over the over the horizon and now
you're seeing that light
before the sun is actually there correct
so now that's so cool so you're getting
a few extra minutes of sunrise
light and a few extra minutes of sunset
light okay
so watch what happens if you
wait around for the equinox
which we glibly say i will and my
colleagues and everyone who knows will
globally say
equal day and equal night
12 hours a day and 12 hours a night if
on that day
you look up in the tables what time the
sun rises
and what time the sun sets it is not it
does not split the day
into 12 and 12. because of this extra
five minutes on each side
so in fact the equinoxes give you
ten around it depends on what your
latitude is but about
10 minutes more sunlight than a pure 12
and 12 would
splice it to be so if you're one of
these people who likes looking up these
tables
you can you can wiki them or google them
you look up the table sunrise sunset
if you want to find the day when you
actually have 12 hours of sunlight and
12 hours of darkness
it will not be on the equinoxes even
though i have told you
we have equal day and equal night
because it's too much to explain all the
rest of this that i just did
so i'm going to leave it at that and if
you come to me later and say where
doctor tyson i looked it up and it's not
true
come into my office now we can explain
the and now i can give you the full
explanation
wow that is phenomenal
because i'm not giving i'm not coming
out of the box giving you that full
explanation
exactly if you didn't know the 12 and 12
to begin with and the origin of the word
and all the rest of that
once you once you come out of the box
then we'll give you the full explanation
and there you go right now you're going
to need to know basis
[Laughter]
as an educator at all times my audience
is on a need to know basis at all times
so
let's let's do that experiment you ready
i'll do it with you okay okay so chuck
um what
path is earth's orbit around the sun
what shape is that path
uh so it's a it's a round
[Laughter]
i love that vocabulary chuck it's around
man it's a wrap
it's an ellipse had i told you
it was a circle would you have called me
out on that
i would have because i could i would say
that we are we already had that model of
the solar system
it's very good okay so here's the thing
if you didn't know
earth moved at all then i'll probably
start out that explanation saying earth
goes in circles around the sun
what the sun doesn't go around the earth
all right so so so that first
foray i don't want to get too it's not
you don't need to get complicated yet
because you want to get the basic ideas
across okay
so then we put we go around circle and
we said wait a minute the circle is not
not working as we need oh you know
because it's not actually a circle
it's an ellipse okay a slightly
flattened circle
which is the answer you gave me so chuck
you're happy with this
with your lips explanation you're having
i'm good with that okay good
that's because you're on a need to know
basis oh so you're saying that it's
not an ellipse earth's actual orbit
around the sun
is not an ellipse oh
i ran out of time in this explainer
video to tell you why
oh so now that i need to know i can't
know
so we're gonna have to put that in
another explainer video at another time
all right that's cool now let me get
back to the sunlight in the 12 hours a
day at night
so this refraction is just kind of a fun
fact
about the sun because you see it not
where it
is but where the refraction of light
allows you right i see it that's right
that's i love that though
that that's really cool because you're
never really looking at what you're
looking at
and and let's let's let's finish it
which is not only is the sun not where
you think it is on the sky for all the
reasons i've given
there's other sort of ghosts of the sky
that i think are worthy of just
just putting out there all right when
you look up at the stars
yes all right oh by the way they refract
through these angles as well
just saying that that makes sense life
is light light light is light in fact
when i'm at a telescope observing a star
their coordinates
are the pure coordinates assuming earth
has no atmosphere
and the telescope knows the angle at
which you are viewing the star
relative to the horizon and it
calculates
the refractive um effects
of earth's atmosphere on that uh
starlight and it moves the telescope
into that position
not the position of the star in the
catalog that's so cool man
because we got people who know how to do
that
same yeah well yeah i'm pretty sure you
would need those
we got good people but but not only that
those stars not only go through this
refractive thing but
this is light that they emitted tens
hundreds thousands millions and in some
cases billions of years ago
they're all just ghosts so they may not
even be there you're seeing light from
something that's not even there
this goes from things that may or may
not even exist
that is really i mean that's
i mean i mean i understand it completely
yes but it's
really kind of eerie to think about and
cool because like we
when you cut off a flashlight you just
there's no way you can distinguish
the light that last left the flashlight
you can't distinguish that because
everything goes dark
and you can't make that perception but
what you're saying is
here's this super brilliant luminous
thing in the sky a star
okay and it's beaming for billions of
years and then all of a sudden
it's gone but all of that stream of
material
that that those that light that came
from it
is still on that path it's still coming
at you and you're receiving all that
information
and then at one point it's gonna be gone
but it was going a long time before that
dude that is amazing i love it it's like
the dancing fountains at the
at the uh i love those it's like yeah
it's where they it's not just well it's
not just there you go to many theme
parks have this
right dancing fountains yeah the
children playing it so yes
these are fountains that are at an angle
right and they'll put a spigot of
a stream of water that comes up right
the fountain turns off and you see you
see the stream of water going so it's
just like that but with
light dude that's fantastic
that is amazing in fact in fact
since you took me there okay
if earth were a black hole
a beam of light would do exactly what
those streams of water are doing around
the black hole
because the curvature of space-time is
that strong
you turn on a beam of light you see the
beam go up and down right
right right yes oh that's amazing i love
it
that is oh that's so god the universe is
so beautiful in so many ways
it's beautiful it's beautiful beautiful
so
so that's the sun it's refraction it's
the fake
sunrises and sunsets 12-hour day and
night
and uh kind of reminds me of that poem
recited
at the end of the moody blues song
knights in white satin
did you know that no i don't i know the
i know the song oh so you cut off the
song before the the most beautiful part
of the song came out which is
a spoken poem at the end well i was i
was listening for the song
because you it's the song the song i
wanted to hear
the song okay but at the end there's
actually a recitation it begins
breathe deep the gathering gloom
watch lights fade from every room that's
how it begins but what i'm thinking of
is the last line in it
which is in the theme of this whole
explainer video
but we decide which is right
and which is an illusion nice
oh i like it what a perfect ending to
what we've been talking about
the sun you're a liar
you're a liar son chuck that will not
make it into poetry i'm sorry
all right we got to drop it there chuck
always good to have you always a
pleasure babe
all right i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
once again bidding you keep looking up